[Applause]
[Music]
you
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect yo what's up everybody I
am Thomas doola whatever you want to
call me I'm with my co-host Marty O'Neal
what's up guys what up guys we are back
with another episode of the dope as
usual podcast we are here to guys let's
get straight into it we're here today
with bootleg Kev what's up guys thanks
for the invite thanks for being here
thanks for being directly on time early
we're not Brothers for everybody
wondering yeah I could see that you know
we ask a lot nice nice fellow white you
know what I sayand the other day some
some nice whites I don't want what you
say I don't want to be I don't want to
be linked with those whites no no I was
like you're like you want to come to
Ireland I'm like bunch of cold whites oh
a bunch of cold wh That's what you said
cold drunk whites in Ireland cold drunk
whites are you Irish you know I so
recently I had always been told that I
was German and Irish but recently my
parents got their 23 and me thing and
they're full of [__] I'm like 5% Irish
oh what's the Rest
German
English something else that I I was a
kind of a game I didn't expect I forget
was another white country though mhm
right it a lot of white you know a lot
of white and then you know like most
whites swear they got like some sort of
native in them and like my whole life my
grandma was showing me pictures of her
grandma who looks like an Indian lady
and I have less than 1% Indian in me so
I'm like what the well then who was that
lady she just found a picture of the of
the flea market like it's the Heritage I
I will say if if we put some 1940s
clothes on both of you uhhuh yeah we
could be
yeah you could it could work yeah yeah
no we're I mean yeah generation are you
Irish oh I'm full [__] blood in yeah
I see it yeah big time you guys look
like you're from peeky blinders yeah
both of you this a nice little top
button I haven't seen the show but I get
the reference oh the show is Bomb is it
what's the guy's name Bane's in it right
Bane the guy who plays Bane and Batman
Hardy oh Tom Hardy Tom he's in that too
damn you're right but the guy that plays
the other guy in Batman
the guy that does no he's in the he's
the main character of that movie I mean
of that show okay okay the main
character of that show he was in the
other Batman the guy that the
psychologist do from that one oh yeah
yeah yeah you're right yeah yeah I can't
remember I I didn't wasn't a huge fan of
the Christian Bales I know people
crucify me on that what are which Batman
are you a fan of like [__] oh Michael
ke George Clooney Michael Keaton I mean
yeah the Mich I mean listen they I'm
gonna be honest the uh
patson Batman is not bad the emo one
that is a solid movie it was wasn't
Batman to me it was more like yo
detective damn you're rich he was like
the most normal Batman where you
believed he could die and he wasn't like
I was like oh this is like a reasonable
Batman this Batman could OD yes for sure
he a LIF feel yeah for sure what
lifestyle Batman lifestyle Batman yeah
regular billion poverty Batman yeah yeah
nice Cut Batman yeah I don't know how
they see I I remember what was in the
early 90s when it first came out I don't
know all the second and third Renditions
of Spider-Man and Batman it's like how
do they keep retelling these stor I like
the one with the football field and Bane
money money money they're like that's
why they're like uh hey that was a good
idea new Spider-Man yeah re right back
but I think what they're about to do is
start remaking Spider-Man movies with
the other Spider-Mans cuz now the
Multiverse is out there so now they can
do like The Amazing Spider-Man part
three with the one dude Andrew Garfield
and then they can bring back the other
Spider-Man the uh Toby yeah they're like
chemists with drugs yeah what can we Mi
I mean they're just trying to you know
take money from us and it's going to
happen it's going to work good movies
don't exist much I mean they're all
franchises and remakes at this point you
know yeah what's the last Good original
movie you saw I don't even [__] know
man did you watch that
uh everything everywhere that's the yes
that's a great movie and it won all the
awards and it parasite you watch
parasite didn't see parasite you seen
that [__] it's in another I had to read
for two hours and I was hooked won it
was Korean right it was Korean and won
the Oscar and you best film is a de deal
breaker for me you should just go into
listen city of God is one of the
greatest movies ever one my favorite
movies it's in Portuguese but great it's
the most gangster [__] you'll ever watch
oh [__] you'd love it it's like a top 10
movie all time you would you would
definitely be buying a poster who I'm
trying to picture the cover it's like
it's a a kid back of a kid's head right
or a GU it's a guy and a girl on the
beach but it's like about this this
there's this kid named little dice oh I
remember that that was the goog doll
song right on the soundtrack Super
Famous that's a really white uh thing to
say no it's a buffalo that's a buffalo
thing yo the goooo dolls right no it's a
it's a movie that's from Brazil what is
that have to do with the gooo doll
Gisela records with the gooo doll Studio
that's true hey I've been there you have
it you I've been there I was there uh I
don't know was it last year with Conway
and sick and I had some of that pizza
was it Nova something Nova yeah yeah
good pizza good Wings by the way the new
era store in Buffalo is a [__] joke
why what happened bro it's [__]
terrible you go to Buffalo and it's the
home of New Era they got this [__]
flagship store right across the street
from my hotel we go in it's [__] no
you know why it's not [__] cuz it's
something oh because buffal has nothing
it's our but no there's better New Era
selections at a LIDS in [__] no
really two song I was looking for
pictures we had Benny on he was talking
about it and I was looking on Google for
pictures of it I'm like thought they'd
have some better pictur like yeah it
sucks I got an NWO New Era from there
though so NWO the wrestling yeah that's
cool that was I was like at least I got
something well I had to buy something
they had every variation of a [__]
bills hat in there yeah what the [__] am
we're cool now bills is like Inc
commercials and [__] they're in yeah
they got Tik Tok they got an Instagram
Josh Allen man yep you know where Josh
Allen's from fireball California right
by her said Fireball Fireball like b a u
a g h dumb I say
Fireball so he's from the middle of
California from the boonies wow good for
him went to Wyoming dope we don't get
nothing are you a big football fan huge
oh here we go you guys not related right
I feel like you have a strong opinion on
Josh oh he's great M he's uh one of my
leagues my fantasy quarterback nice I've
never done I've never did fantasy it's a
lot to keep up with right too much
it's every year I say I'm a quit have
you ever won the whole thing yeah yeah
oh okay fantasy league I I just somebody
tried to explain it to me the other day
I'm like so you get to pick the best
people ever and just win no you have to
well first of all it depends on how many
teams are in your league I don't do a
league unless it's 12 teams or
more
actually the pool of players then the
pool of players becomes harder to pick
from so like there's guys who are in
like eight League team or eight team
leagues and it's like everyone's team is
loaded because there's only eight teams
picking and then so the more teams that
are in your league the more you have to
kind of like take risks maybe grab a
backup running back that you hope you
know like it makes you really apply
yourself to being a you know it's not
some rookie [__] it's not on novice
Madden correct I get you do you do
sports betting yes okay we're about to
do our first ever bets coming up right
now I think on the upcoming UFC I bet a
lot on my bookie of course shout out to
my bookie correct likewise are you guys
on my bookie let's go my bookie we go do
you give a what's the advice like what
should we do if you had a budget what
would you do on um on the fights well
obviously it's like YouTubers this
weekend right it's like Dylan dannis and
Lan Paul on
football I always try to look for home
dogs and if there's a home dog that's
like anything over four like let's say
or even anything over three like let's
say it's plus three and a half plus four
plus four and a half just by like a rule
I'll usually bet on the home dog now
somebody doesn't know what that means us
right so I like that when you uh in in
like sports betting they you have odds
right so you'll have a face favorite and
you'll have an underdog so how that
works is let's say the Buffalo Bills
were
playing uh the patriots the patriots
suck this year right do they they're
[__] I haven't watched football this
whole oh God so listen so they're
[__] terrible right so the bills if
they played in Buffalo would probably be
somewhere between a nine and 10-point
favorite which means when you bet it you
would see minus 9 next to the Bill's
name now what that means is that in the
eyes of the better the book when the
game starts if you bet on Buffalo they
it doesn't start zero to zero in the
better eyes it starts Buffalo has minus
9 and the other team has zero so if you
bet on the Patriots you're betting on
them plus nine so that
means the game starts with the Patriots
already got nine points so as long as
the Patriots can lose and you can still
win as long as they lose by 10 I can't
believe I've never had any sort of
concept with those well you guys haven't
you guys don't know about this listen
this like that I'm just like yo who's
going to win just spreads there you go
and so that's so usually so most people
would bet the spread right so you would
say if I okay I love this Underdog I
don't think the Patriots it's a division
game I don't think they're going to lose
by more than nine they might lose but
they might lose by a field goal or they
might lose by a touchdown but they're
not going to Lans so want to bet
Patriots plus n give me that you'll hear
people say give me the points I'll take
the points being Patriots with the
points so that means if you bet on the
Patriots you have a ninepoint head start
in the eye of the book that you bet with
so that means as long as they don't lose
like if they if they lose by eight you
win your money if they lose by nine it's
a wash it's a you you just you keep your
money you don't win any money you keep
your money if they lose by 10 you lose
this exciting a lot of mob movies just
made more sense right now you can bet
money line which is just I'm betting
that they're going to win no matter what
that's what I would now if you bet money
line on a favorite you're G to get
shitty odds so you might bet patri let's
say same example Patriots bills the
money line for the bills would probably
be minus
400 the odds so that means you're going
to bet the bills are going to win
straight up don't matter by how many or
whatever but for every hundred you have
to bet $400 to win a 100 oh no no no no
I get it now yeah it's like oh on the
contrary if you bet that the Patriots
are going to win it'd probably be
something like plus 650 so if you bet a
100 you win 650 cuz they're the
underdog so for example last week I
actually bet against your bills because
they played the Jaguars in London and
the Jaguars were already in London from
the week before that's what they the
Jaguars were in London hanging out for
two weeks on the sleep schedule used to
playing out there they're kind of
already the the London Jaguars at this
point Buffalo had to fly all the way to
[__] London and play the Jaguars who
aren't a bad team they haven't gotten
off to the best start but I liked the
Jags to win and and upset and also the
bills just embarrassed the Dolphins so
anytime something like that happens I
like to be like yo the bills are filling
themselves this week they got to drop
fly all the way to [__] you thought
about all of these things these factors
yeah and then I you know I put a serious
bet down on the Jaguars I didn't I was
who the quarterback all right Co yeah
damn so you guys are oh yeah everything
he just said is what the coach
attributed the loss to
so cuz you'll see like and then the
other thing is is like you could you
know if you're like a real [__] I'm
not like a super [__] I mean I bet a
lot but I'm not man I I do I mean you
would like look at like okay is there
who's injured you look at the injury
report a lot of times if someone's
offensive line is depleted and they're
favored just bet the other way like just
you know that the other way okay that
[__] just happened with uh somebody's
old line was just [__] up oh the
Cowboys when they lost to the Cardinals
my Cardinals who suck oh so you're a
Cardinal fan unfortunately because
you're from there though yeah so you
don't I mean you know if you weren't
from there who would you who was your
favorite team I couldn't even answer
that question oh my God you're that he
was born into the show wow I was born
around R honest you know what I take
that back I'd be an Eagles fan is it
because I grew up loving Randle
Cunningham Rand Cunningham is a badass
so I loved R Cunningham and then I love
Dante Co
pepper so I would say I would I would
for
sure 1,000% be an Eagles fan wow or a
Vikings fan
because no no co co pepper was on the
Vikings I just had a brain fart um but I
but Cunningham was on the Eagles and on
the Vikings and when the Vikings had
Randy Moss and you know Chris Carter and
the other what was the third guy they
had three three guys had a thousand
yards in one season I forgot who it was
but it would been the Vikings or the uh
it would probably been the Eagles Don
McNab was cold like that he has to get
some when that Super Bowl when uh when
uh too came back in the Super Bowl we
talking about TI the other day y it's
messed up ABS messed up ABS they should
have won that [__] game damn see I
just remember chunky soups and his mom
like yo Don now is about to shake
someone and then Chuck it if it goes by
the points how does that apply to the
UFC oh so UFC is just odds right so like
a fight you're going to either bet on
the favorite or bet on the underdog to
win bet that's how I want to bet so
you're going to see like you could pull
up the odds on the fight right so let's
say like Logan Paul
um on I don't I don't know who Dylan
danis was until three and a half hours
ago he explained that he's he's a
sparring partner right or training with
mcregor he's pretty much McGregor's butt
buddy okay so right now Logan Paul is a
minus 580 favor
to win the fight those are the odds
minus 580 that means Logan Paul in order
for you to win $100 you have to bet
$580 damn sounds
terrible people would take that bet yeah
to win $100 because if if they feel like
he's such a favorite like no matter what
he's winning like you could throw down
like technically you could bet 58 Grand
to win 10 o
but you could also lose 58 Grand and be
pissed and be suicidal oh what do you
make of the whole Saga round in this
fight I mean I haven't like watched the
podcast and [__] that theyve I mean I
obviously know all the like surface
level back and forth [__] it's the
highest level trolling of a boxing fight
it's up there it's up there right it's
definitely uh like today I think dude
threw a mic at Logan pong that's all I
saw this morning yeah that's what it
look like yeah I mean uh I it I told my
boy today I said said uh you actually
might pay for this now these [__] are
selling this fight in a really nice way
don't you hate when you get CAU no I
actually thought like to and then I saw
Thomas Fury's dad like punching the
[__] glass in front of KSI did you
see that today oh my God it was [__]
crazy I don't know so they did a face
off but they put a a piece of plexiglass
between them in this box CU they didn't
want them fighting each other and Tomas
Fury's dad just starts punching the PCH
the the glass yelling at KS I'll [__]
kill you a YouTu yeah and who's Tommy F
he's a real boxer he's uh I believe he's
the man who beat Logan Jak Paul right
he's an actual fighter not sure about
that so he's Fury the Tyson Fury's
little brother who beat Jake Paul oh
[__] Tyson Fury is a monster so his
little brother is a a boxer they do not
look alike and his little brother beat
is the only person to beat Jake Paul
what did you think of the NS fight I
didn't I don't know I just know he's
from Stockton my kid's into UFC it's not
my no when he fought Jake Paul oh I
watched that yeah yeah I I watched the I
watched the YouTube [__] oh it was
cool I mean I think uh I think Logan
Paul's or Jake Paul is a decent boxer
like he's a above like he's a good box
he's not even a decent boxer he's a
pretty good boxer
so I mean dude the UFC [__] and the
boxing [__] is very different I thought
it would translate better I thought it
would translate like more to like uh
like an NBA player shooting free throws
only think about it like there's the
dunk
contest and then there's the three-point
shoot
out both are basketball but both are
different like somebody who wins the
dunk contest might not be able to go
into the three-point content they might
get washed they might look okay though
cuz they're still professional
basketball players a good way to put it
that's perfect actually perfect way to
put it but like you're in the
Three-Point
Contest use leg kicks in this one and
like jerk Nowitzki would win the
Three-Point Contest right and he can
dunk he can dunk yes but he's not going
to get past the first round analogies
out that are very on point like that was
that was perfect high LEL shirt right
there was good pulled it out of my ass
it's all right that's where half the
show is I feel you um well thank you for
explaining betting yeah don't do it guys
it's a dick I mean do it on my
bookie uh
do it on my bookie but also understand
it is extremely
addicting so career-wise are you up or
down oh I'm down oh
no I just started gambling for the first
time like three months I had like a bad
run in 2019 I probably lost about 30
Grand in one month and uh betting online
God Dam betting on my bookie shout out
to my bookie you're really in but you
guys are sponsor by my bookie I've got
my money back from so call it even so
check this out the my bookie guys hit me
up this guy watched like an interview I
did with cannabis and he was like hey
man I handle all the stuff with my
bookie like I [__] I like your [__]
like would love to get involved I'm like
cool so I was like dude I'm I'm like a
huge customer like they send me stuff in
the mail oh like they send me like
hoodies jackets oh the jackets remember
when you smoke so much they send you a
[__] jacket so he's like oh let me
look up your account and I sent him it
and he was like
oh [__] you weren't lying and I was like
nah
buddy this [__] is in me it ain't on
me so at least I've you know gotten some
money back from them nice and a cool
sweater and a
basketball can't put a price on that and
what's those things uh that you can put
drinks in and they kind of Koozies no no
no they're like a it's like a you know
like a thermos like a yeah like a really
lowlevel thermos with their logo at my
house right now all right I'll take it
right hey man you can put stuff in it I
can put anything in I can I can put my
tears in there after I
leave like Cry Baby for sure you're like
a sponsored pro athlete damn nearly
you're almost like a pro like poker
player right like you can justify my
bookie way more now you got the mug
laying around and Sh yeah I mean shout
out to my bookie man great service The
Bitter Sweet the best part about my
bookie is you go on there and you could
like go on the casino and like you can
play like Blackjack it's and like you're
looking at a human like you're like
there's a lady on a webcam dealing cards
oh that's we've only done the other
stuff we haven't done the remember we
said Live casino it's really live live
casino Oh you mean like a human yeah no
like it's a real Casino like it's not
like so you can do like slots and stuff
or like video game type roulette and
Blackjack but then there's like the
actual like you'll be on there and
there's like a Dominican lady
like dealing you in yeah yo we got to go
live and do this [__] I think they're in
the Dr or somewhere in Latin America
surrounded by
water well we're all surrounded by water
somewhere on all sides surrounded by
water oh okay different Mexico not all
sides surrounded by water I
mean maybe eventually eventually
eventually hey when the world war
happens Mexico's the dark horse
winner they're going to come and rebuild
all our [__] yeah all my cousins I'm
okay with that and like you say we got
to refinish this Warehouse like we got
to finish this
up call my cousin and they'll come and
move your [__]
too Sor we got way off topic my [__]
family does moving sorry do they yeah
that's why I even brought it good gig
it's not maybe not a good gig that's why
he's almost paralyzed right now right uh
throw your back out no my back's all
trash dude my back's been real bad is it
CU you were moving pianos as a child
that I used to do like competition
weight stuff oh you used to be a lifter
for real lifter mhm wow oh High schol
and um my back hurts all the time we
recently went to the doctor and the MRIs
and they're like no you're done so I've
been doing all these procedures go do
stem cell in Mexico and Tijuana no I've
been doing the softwave stem cells that
they do here with this big machine thing
it's weird but I'm doing the
decompression where they stretch your
back does it work it's been working nice
Joe Rogan would tell you to go to Mexico
and see some and TJ somebody already
offered me the same thing I heard it's
great I mean those fools are lumps of
muscle so I I I I probably agree with it
like yo my back's better MH well I heard
like if you tear something or your
shit's [__] up like it almost like
just revitalizes it to brand
new like it's almost like the stem shell
the stem cell [__] but it's not legal
here yeah it's not you can do it in
Arizona though I don't think you can I
just got the I think you can do a form
of stem cell but you can't do like the
real [__] the real one okay well I just
got the I got the information is in
Phoenix I believe I don't think it's
like the [__] the dope [__] it's like a
version of it that's legal here it's the
light you got to go to Mexico take a
couple lights youever Tian is a great
place man great food I just like lobster
straight out of the water right on your
plate oh my God sounds crazy f [__]
still trying to fight for his family and
[__] right out of the water like find I
think of everything like finding we get
like a $11 lobster tail and it's like
[__] is that cheap as [__] for
honestly best food I've ever had in my
life is in
Mexico Tiana no like Tiana specifically
Tiana the best seafood ever I imagine
you're probably like World traveled like
you've been around I wouldn't say World
traveled you never you been to Europe
once Paris how was that it was cool I
went with my girl for like four days it
was very after three days you're like
I'm ready to leave I everywhere 20 17
was it Wilder no it was very not wild
and very boring and the food suck or
something honestly yes the food didn't
suck but it wasn't what you would have
expected and I blame that probably more
on me not knowing where to go but I was
TI like crepes are everywhere croissants
are
everywhere little mini bikes are
everywhere like everyone's on a [__]
moped there's no lines in the
street oh like no lines in the street
right the Eiffel Tower is over at as
[__] just some metal they had one at the
americ it was really cold and like it
took forever to get to the top it was
[__] I would yeah I
mean and then uh well you made me want
to go the church hey the church was cool
they got like this old church how old
scary like haunt
your I think it might be the Notre Dame
Church the one from like the hunb one I
think so or that guy with multiple
sceris like that girl listen some
[__] gnarly church is out there and
then I went down to the catacombs which
is like oh hell no all the skulls and
[__] you went in it yeah we walked
through the whole [__] it was in Arley
the catacombs is [__] all the skulls
the walls are made of human skulls
skulls I don't know this is in uh Italy
right France it's in France Paris it's
in Pat how do they have one in France I
mean in Italy I mean the I know the main
catacombs is in Paris oh you you go like
deep under people that die deep
underground wall it's like these tunnels
underground from like the 1400s or some
[__] and walls are all human skulls you
could pick them up like there's like
bones everywhere it's made out of B like
like the like like a level of Mortal
Kombat yes it looks like scorpions level
bones of people like back then yes yeah
[__] human
skulls and I want to say this a nobody
has evolved the same skulls from today
same [__] hey man we evolved from this
like have we yeah look I mean it's you
can walk up and touch them and [__] look
at that that's those all skeletons
that's like the you play in The Goonies
to get out of the [__] cave it's like
a layer of like Earth when you dig down
oh it's like deep in in the did you feel
safe going down there
yeah do you like haunted
houses like the real ones we going in a
haunted no a haunted house like for for
for Halloween yeah I don't mind them oh
okay see yeah I wouldn't even go near
one I thought you meant like do you like
to go like find houses where people died
in and hang out that place that place is
a house where people died yeah I love
haunted houses you do oh wow yeah I've
never been in one I don't I wouldn't say
listen I wouldn't say I love haunted
houses I enjoy them I'll go the tickets
are free I won't pay to go do you [__]
with scary
movies certain scary movies I think
scary movies are the worst movies
they're terrible they're [__] there
zero thought put into them every once in
a while you get one
uh what's that one there's a few that
are like really good like there's the
one where like every every time somebody
dies the thing gets passed on to another
person and that the movie poster is like
a trunk I forget but that [__] every
once in a while like when Saul first
like the first sa we were just talking
about that you see the first saw and
you're like oh this is different yeah
Princess Bride no now you know it's like
all these demon movies are all the
[__] same I don't watch them at all
[__] Conjuring [__] Evil Dead all
this [__] is the same wait the Evil Dead
no no there's a new evil dead that's
like some Demon [__] Bruce Campbell hard
no no that [__] the TV show was good did
you watch show Bruce versus evil I think
yes super good um but like yeah horror
movies are usually just some real
low-level Vie if there was 50 of them in
existence that would be way better and
they were just yeah they were just over
and over no they drop them every year
there's a new Exorcist that they just
redid my wife likes them my wife is my
wife likes terrible movies is she into
just murder shows and stuff in general
yeah yeah how is this such a reoccurring
topic my [__] wife will sit on Hulu
or Tik well first of all if she get off
[__] Tik
Tok but she'll put [__] whatever's on
Hulu whatever murder mystery [__]
documentary it's just non to the end
just that's all that's on has she
crossed over to watching it in the
morning no no only at night at bed like
bedtime let me throw it on you know
which isn't really cool either yo let's
get all [__] scared and sleep yeah no
that's a a recipe for my wife's not
capable of watching a like a slow
building
anything she's like this [__] how long
have you been with your wife uh since
2016 okay the way you're saying it's
like she likes terrible ass movies no
she she admits that her movie taste is
terrible but how do you like [__] movies
CU she'll like a movie like uh I'm
trying to think like what's like one of
her favorite movies that like she
[__] love like she likes to show
Charmed right joh why that sound for CU
it was on the WB Network with the Three
Chicks yeah I remember that my grandma
watched that so this show sucks it did
and it still sucks but it's on Netflix
and she'll still throw it on like it's
good and I'm like this didn't age well
it wasn't good then it's definitely not
good now but she enjoys it the three
prettiest [__] in town she watches
the Kardashians oh hell no does she
watch a lot of just [__] arguing on
each other no no just the Kardashian
[__] arguing at each other if they're
not killing each other they're [__]
arguing at each other in my house it's
like
the first time ever seen Bad Bad Girls
Club you ever seen that [__] I know
obviously know what it is but I never
got engaged in it oh no Rosie watch that
[__] I don't like that's why I'm just
I'm done with living there like I used
to live around I'm good on that I just
like I want to laugh at funny [__]
that's really it MH yeah I'm I'm good at
we're on we're on Halloween topics here
let's get the [__] off of it I hate
scary movies all right since we've been
here for half an hour you're Bole Kev we
haven't talked about you at all we just
talked about betting and how we hate
scary movies enjoy the enjoy enjoy the
addiction out
there that's a good [__] slogan enjoy
the addiction enjoy the addiction put it
on a hoodie no Thomas was telling me
when he went to your studio was just
covered in plaques I wouldn't say
covered there's plaques he said I would
covered there's there's plaques there
can you give us some background of your
life in the music industry yeah so uh
I've been doing
radio since I mean technically since I
was 16 on like a serious level since I
was
18 um so that was I'm 36
so knocking on 20
years um I just you know I've I've done
radio in a bunch of different cities I
started off in my hometown Phoenix I
moved to Boise Idaho which [__] why
sucked why why' you do that my first
fulltime gig had to take oh yeah hip hop
radio yeah wild 101 Boise Ido yeah lots
of Mormons storm and Mormons were there
like Utah oh yeah pretty small Market I
would imagine for hip-hop guest coming
through super small yeah so there there
I I do I do I did interview nipy I have
a nipy freestyle on YouTube from Boise
in '
09 and I have a tech 9 Ms freestyle wait
Tech9 Ms when he signed to Strange Music
yeah that a that was 2010 so in ' 09
both of them were on tour together Tech
and mge came on my show in freestyle
that's on
YouTube um I interviewed the game in
Boise I was only there for a year did
anything stand out about the nipy
interview yeah I mean I was I was
[__] with nipy like when he came he
came into town with the game Steve LEL
was managing him La extor yeah that's it
and uh nip came up to the station we did
an interview he was cool as [__] at the
time I think Bulls ain't got no names
volume one or two was out and um G
freestyled over the truth beat Brother
Ali oh wow and Jake
won and uh yeah he was cool I went to
the show that night hung out with him
you know hung out with the game I've
known the game for a long time so uh
yeah I mean nips [__] you know and
then I I probably interviewed
nip probably seven times eight times
maybe seven
seven it's all on YouTube M yeah you
know been locked in with him well before
everybody else was mhm he was dope
that's a a throwback the first date I
ever went on was a m show with my wife
love Ms yeah especially like the felt
[__] and the [__] yeah him and slug
that was the one I was talking about the
one I have in my house mhm yeah I saw Ms
uh early like uh as a kid too like I
remember he was doing like back flips on
stage he came out on stage to [__]
cold play Scarab too right you do the
back flips was the Scarab in Liv Legends
it's just him oh okay I forget which
album he was touring it's probably mer
for president if no it was before that
CU mer for president's when he went on
he got he signed to the major label yeah
yeah no mer for president was after but
it's one where he's the toy on the cover
it was um it was the around the first
nth Wonder
album the night and that's where he just
on the C 316 no was first one first oh
no that's the white the first one's
black the second one's white yeah the
white and then he just him on the cover
yeah mhm so what was going on when you
were 16 and now you're in radio were you
just like pitching yourself oh no I was
um I was uh I went to high school at a
place called well I went to high school
at a place called Westwood high but they
had a technical school nearby called
evit East Valley Institute of Technology
you could choose to go to this vocation
School leave campus go to the vocational
school instead of doing an elective at
your home school so this school had like
auto body repair cosmetology culinary
arts and radio broadcasting so I did
radio broadcasting my last two years of
high school at that place and we we had
a radio show that actually was on it
surrounded the school like two miles so
like if you driving around he can hear
you guys talking [__] right so
technically that's why I say technically
I was on the radio when I was 16
technically but it was like a school
thing and then when I graduated I
interned at the radio station and then
um yeah and then I just kept like kind
of working my way up I've
lived Phoenix Vegas Tampa off for Radio
LA yeah Boise those are yeah those are
all yeah Boise yeah and now I'm still on
the radio but I'm on I have a syndicated
show so now I'm on in 20 some odd cities
every day I'm on in La every night 700
to 11 you do it at your studio yeah pre
I the show's pre-recorded so I record a
show every day that runs the next day so
if you get in your car after this
because we are in La put on 923 you'll
hear my show oh no [__] and it was
recorded yesterday how long is it it's a
4 Hour show oh my God now it's it
doesn't take me four hours to record the
show because there's a bunch of music in
between the parts where I talk oh it's a
hip hop stage so they're playing songs
and I'm I do content in between the
songs how hard is it to do every day not
hard but I don't know it's not I know
it's part of your life but every like
you have like a map of the show right
like you I do five breaks an hour I map
out what what I'm going to talk about so
how much do you really talk like two
hours of that
no way less 20 minutes oh the way you
say it's kind of like I found the rest
it's a 4our show like if you get in the
car you're going to the bootle have
shows from 700 p.m. to 11:00 p.m. where
I'm actually talking is like 20 minutes
probably sprinkle throughout this song
all right now we're back from this song
BL no I see I don't do that because I'm
on in so many different cities and every
city has their own music so I'll just
tease hey coming up we got to talk about
Jada PE Smith's a dirty
[__] how does the music get
picked that's well at what in general at
Radio you have a program director and a
music director and then they schedule
the log gotcha and then how they pick
the music usually is a combination of
songs that research well in the market
the
chart whoever the labels are pushing at
the time how um what's streaming in the
market you could look at charts to see
oh what's streaming high in La we should
be playing this on the radio what's
shazaming in the market you could look
at what songs are shazaming because
usually Shazam is an indicator that
someone is in an Uber and the radio's on
and they don't know the name of the song
song so they Shazam it right hold on
what does that mean again Shazam is an
app it's an app oh oh okay I got you I
got you yeah so like if we were in a
[__] elevator and the song a song was
playing on the speaker you just pull
your phone out or if you're in a
nightclub you pull your phone out Shazam
tells you what song it is okay it's
[__] great so from there they kind of
put together a playlist and you know
their songs that are powers so like a
lot of people complain like I hear the
same [__] on the radio every day which
is true and there's a reason for that
and the reason is 90% radio listeners
listen for 15 minutes a day so if 90% of
the people who listen to radio only
listen for 15 minutes a day you want to
play the music that gives you the most
the biggest chance of retaining the
listenership and keeping it and those
would be the same like certain amount of
songs that research super high so yes
there might be like five songs that you
hear that are somehow in a rotation
throughout the day they get hit every
every hour because those are the five
most popular songs MH so we want to we
it's it's it's all science that's
interesting thought about it that way so
why why is it the same like if you're a
[__] Uber driver and you're in the
car all [__] day you're probably like
God damn it I've heard DOA cat paint the
town red [__] seven times he's like
yeah so do you plan out the next day's
episode in the morning or like after you
film depends it depends so you sometimes
like you know I have to be careful cuz I
have a syndicated show so it's
pre-recorded so I have to be very very
careful about certain like timely [__]
that could change by the next day so and
if something crazy happens like God
forbid an artist passes away or
something then I have to recut something
day of and try to get it on in as many
cities as I can you know send it out to
all the PDS and say hey you guys want to
replace this break for this here's a
break about you know take off dying or
something like that you know um so yeah
I would
say do I plan it in the morning so I
record the show in the morning I
probably plan it like the afternoon and
then some usually day of though because
we are at day ahead of time so we don't
want to pre-plan too much cuz and we're
like two days ahead of time that's
interesting so with that whole steps you
just said about doing this
and about the music industry and itself
from your eyes now everything's changed
from when you started there wasn't
Instagram you just promote yourself and
have a popular song TI Tok get you know
I mean back then obviously what what are
the advice cuz I guarantee there's
people watching right now what's the
advice you give somebody like hey I like
music I can make music do it on my own I
have the drive to do it how do I get
myself out there besides just social
media uh I mean I think the main thing I
would say is uh a couple of things one
people will procrastinate themselves out
of a career they will overthink
themselves out of a career people will
they you know too many people who don't
have actual
fans
will need so much things to be align for
them to finally put out the song that
they they don't know if they should put
out right like
a you got [__] seven songs on a hard
drive that are finished but you're like
ah I got to shoot a video or I don't you
know I got to I got to have some money
to help promote this or dude just put
the [__] music out and don't put out
any albums if you're not if you don't
have a fan base and you put out a whole
album you're extremely probably a little
arrogant that you think a bunch of
people who don't know who you are are
going to sit through 12
songs uh when you don't have any fans
and most people start off without any
fans besides their homies that tell them
their shitty music is good um for the
most part um I would say like yo put out
singles learn the algorithm game with
Spotify every time you drop a new record
you you tend to get about a 5 to 8%
Spike on your listenership on Spotify so
if you think of it that way you have to
be consistent you know like if you're
going to put out a song put out a song
knowing you got the next two or three
planned and ready to drop so there's
some sort of consistency like people
will put out a song and it's not it
doesn't do what they wanted it to do it
doesn't do what they expected it to do
people want instant
gratification and then they get
discouraged and then they don't put out
another song for 9 months or 6 months or
it's just like dude just be
consistent and take shots put up your
shots that's what I would say yeah it's
almost like episodes like keep them
coming yeah it's almost like I mean how
many people do you guys know that
started a podcast and like just don't do
it consistently or like it didn't do
great so they did like six episodes and
then they like it stopped they I know
tons of people like that and it's like
dude like that's not how this [__] works
like people really want instant
gratification yeah that's the problem
it's social media too it's you get
instant 100 100% And to me like you know
I'm just like yo anything you're going
to do cuz listen podcast space YouTube
space is very very competitive now so
you you have to be extremely consistent
to break through you know and uh I think
I mean that's obviously with anything
you could apply that with most things in
life but music for sure got to be
consistent got to be consistent yeah
because it was always the model to put
out an album per year right like yo
we're going to put out an album we're
going to do we got a single we're going
to go to R
radio man listen all that [__] is gone
like you could go to radio but you got
to have like [__] $50 to $100,000 for
it to even matter and you're not going
to see your money the ROI on that is
crazy it's terrible
30 radio is the final step any artist
should ever look at it used to be one of
the first steps radio used to help break
artists it doesn't anymore it's over
radio's [__] we're cooked you I mean
like we don't break artists anymore we
help artists go number one like you
can't go number one on Billboard without
[__] radio rotation it's just not
possible right
so um you know I think that uh that
would be the thing I would say is like
just kind of have your ducks in a row
have a plan and don't overthink it man
you overthink yourself out of I mean I
got a friend of mine who's been he's
huge on Tik Tok and him and his wife are
hilarious together and they've been
talking about doing a podcast for like
two years and I'm like each of them have
a huge following on Tik Tok and I'm like
y what's up with the podcast oh man you
know we got to get the set right and I'm
just like
dude it's probably best you don't do it
cu the
sh what are y'all doing you know so yeah
people outthink themselves they
procrastinate themselves out of you know
fear of all that work or fear of fear of
the marketplace not getting being into
it initially yeah and also like if
you're dope it'll cut through if you're
consistent if you [__] suck no matter
how consistent you are no one will ever
give a [__] if you [__] suck if you
suck you suck bro yeah you know nothing
past that do some other [__] Bud yeah
you that's solid like if you do a
[__] podcast and your [__] is God
awful and it's shot on a [__] iPhone
9 I did they make an iPhone 9 probably I
don't think they did I think they jumped
from a to X um they did they they
skipped the nine um with that being said
uh you know and if and if you're not
engaging if you're not entertaining no
one there's nobody just don't got it do
something else if you suck at making
music you suck I love the way you're
talking he so long he's just so and I
tell people this all the time I'll tell
people like
dude you're wasting your life real
energy and real money on being horrible
you've been
there's people from my hometown that
have been rapping for 15
years that [__]
suck and they have a [__] nin to-5
and this this applies to every city by
the way this is not just
Phoenix you you got your N9 to5
supporting your rap hobby because that's
all it is at this point you know cuz you
[__] suck that studio time's not
cheap well it is cheaper now you could
record yourself now you know go get
[__] scarlet and shitty Mike and
you're you know you're in Scarlet it's a
little [__] cheap interface you can
get from uh anywhere it's a little red
thing it's like this but small and yeah
this is you know this is an interface
the
roadter but yeah if you suck you [__]
suck I love that though no amount of
consistency and also work and dedication
will save you yeah it doesn't matter at
that point you also have to be a
self-aware enough to know that you
[__]
suck I people need that they really do
yeah yeah and I think I think uh the
participation participation Awards
generation has forgot people just want
to be able to say I'm a
rapper it's like yeah but you
suck yeah you suck
though but there's this thing about you
sucking is the it's not even it's not
even if you suck at like there's artists
whom which I personally am not crazy
about
uh well now was a lot harder though
rap's different rap an example sucks no
I mean it doesn't like okay Playboy
Playboy cardi
right Playboy cardi is uh somebody whom
which I don't quite get okay I do like
his album dialate was dope his [__] he
was doing with ASAP Mob on the um cozy
tapes was cool but like his new
[__] whole lot of red came out on
Christmas I listen to it and I was like
one of the first times in my life where
I was like yeah I don't get it you know
like uh like I get everybody else I got
little pump I got a little Uzi but the
that whole lot of red I was just like
[__] man I'm [__] old you know but I
I I understand what he does apply I I
hear that it can apply to a certain
demographic immediately yeah you always
see I can see people like it yes I can
see why people like it me with cardi
specifically that one album I don't see
why people like it now I understand like
cardi before that I understood why
people liked it and he has this crazy
weird fan base of you know Dusty footed
white [__] at festivals Dusty footed
white I love the descriptions coming
they're
Dusty and they got these [__] up Air
Forces oh that's that's just a given
that's just G like earlier by hate
Mexican cousin that's just a given
anyway so I just say that to say that
like you know there's artists whom which
I can acknowledge I might not
necessarily be a fan of but I get it
right so like you know uh I'm about to
interview Little Rob on
Monday and I love summer nights by the
way That's a classic but like little Rob
like when I was growing up he was doing
all the like low rider shows and like
he's like making like literal Cho rap
right and he had some crossover records
summer nights [__] classic but you
know it obviously wasn't for me you know
but I understood why people liked it you
know what is like a lifetime if we could
take your lifetime most Listen to album
or artist or album artist it's probably
Kanye um album it's probably doggy style
by Snoop
or it's probably doggy
style yeah did you connect with Kanye in
like the I'm good ERA so I met Kanye
when I was 16
okay my best friend's brother is in a
group called Dilated Peoples oh [__]
where com the wor yes so Dilated Peoples
um my best friend from Arizona his Big
Brother's Rocka from Dilated Peoples and
uh so dilated was on tour with Kanye on
The College Dropout
tour um and I got to I was backstage and
I got to uh I got to I got a picture
with Kanye when I was 16 um Wild As
[__] maybe a week before College Dropout
came out I had that burned on a disc
when we almost died on the way to Taho
what I said so like
uh yeah um that's the only time I met
Kanye uh no that's not true I met him
again um I met him at his uh the kidy
ghost uh release thing in Santa
Clarita um I met yeah but that was like
I got to like take a picture with him
and you know yeah it was cool especially
at that age too that his first album was
was everything for me that whole whole
yeah and like even before then like you
know I got put on to him cuz like this
kid at evit the school I was telling you
about my boy David who's my best friend
in the world of this day we met at that
radio school he's a [__] Chanty and
his nickname is David Brett tomman who
likes the
blowman and he
does and he does he
does I love
it what the [__] yo is that his name
your phone his name is David Tom well
you know so his middle name is Brett and
he's a Niner fan and he [__] hates
Brett Favre more than any human being
that's ever existed why because he
[__] smashed on the ners in the
[__] '90s so he hates his middle name
so I always be like David Brett tomman
who likes to blow oh man I love the name
anyway he put me on to yay cuz David
yeah that's what we were talking so D so
my boy David really kind of introduced
me to the internet uh properly uh and
like there was a ER in which you would
go to message boards and download music
um there was like a website like uh
slums of boxon realis nw.com
and and I got introduced to like
pirating music at a high level from
David but he would burn me CDs of like
Kanye like Lucy's from like mixtapes he
had a bunch of mixtapes back in the day
and um so yeah when College Drop Out
came out I was [__] hyped bro I was
ready you know but yeah College Dropout
amazing album it was so cool how he came
in he zippered in behind the scenes with
Jay-Z then he had his own [__] yeah and
like you know I I think the thing that
that yay brought was just uh different
he was wearing polos and talking about
having a job at the mall like he was he
was like he didn't take like he was the
first guy to make it okay to just kind
of be a normal dude it's true that
wasn't like muring and you know selling
drugs it's ironic cuz it was like for
being a humble guy basically just like a
regular dude
he was never humble but no but he just
like like he was a relatable dude
because you were like oh this guy isn't
wearing like a throwback jersey and
smoking spliffs and talking about like
you know bodies just normal [__] you
hear in hip-hop right he was talking
about a whole different side of it like
I'm a I'm not a religious guy at all
Jesus Walks one but like Jesus Walks was
a crazy song like oh this guy made a
song about Jesus and it was nobody's
rapping about Jesus
sure was tough as F damn that was a good
album yeah so yay was like
um different you know and he's always
been different and I I think you know I
think Kanye that's why if I say my most
listened to artist it's probably Kanye
or Naas or uh probably Freddy Gibbs is
up there bro pretty high like pretty
[__] high he's like top five for
sure dude doing a top 10 right now is
very hard I think just cuz it's stacked
but they're all very well the thing
about the top 10 list is there's like
your favorites and there's to be the to
and then there's like the list yes where
it's like okay I have my favorite top 10
which is offensive to a lot of people
I'm sure but then there's like the list
where you're like okay JayZ is number
one you have to say yeah but not like
there's the best rapper alive is not my
favorite that's how I feel it's like I
might think Black Thought is like a top
10 rapper ever of course but like he's
not in the top 10 goat discussion not
because he's not lyrically capable but
because there's other artists who have
been more
impactful uh done more for the game sold
more
records and you know my whole thing with
the roots is like the roots for some of
those albums he wasn't the only rapper
they had dice Raw on some of those
albums and like you know the roots are
amazing one of the greatest groups of
all time but you know [__] you can't
put him above like little
Wayne you can't put him above
Snoop the most famous rapper ever yeah
there's different levels of greatness
with great now lyricism like black th
will [__] wipe his ass with almost
everybody yeah it's back to the
Three-Point Contest yeah ly like like
like like you're not putting Black
Thought above Eminem and Eminem might
out RPP black top but it' be close but
you wouldn't put him above
m in the in in the list now maybe in
your list in your personal my personal
list people like what it's different
it's what you like yeah my personal list
is very different like I don't like
little Wayne's not sniffing my top 10
what's your personal list off the top of
my head it's tough man I I mean top
three personal favorites though personal
it's
Jay Kanye and Nas personal but that's
kind of like the but in my personal list
in my personal yeah but my personal list
I have Ghost Face Killer really high I
have Freddy really high I
have Kendrick higher than than
most
um who else oh I have common pretty high
like resurrection and go and [__]
like resurrection's amazing Common's
like one of the greatest rappers of all
time and he's like still super he's in
like he's in I mean Common's like kind
of like you know he's like a meme now
you know he's like John Wick and [__]
he's like he's a [__] actor now like
John Wick but like the guy with with the
beard yeah like he's like a yeah he's
he's you know but I have common a lot
higher than most people probably have
big pun a lot higher than most people
Big L A lot higher than most people but
you know I would say my list is probably
you know like you said my top three is
probably and the thing is is Kanye is
like different to me because he didn't
write a lot of his own like he has help
a lot of help with writing like Ryan
Fest used to help write for him
SII I mean [__] Drake's written [__]
for
Kanye so I didn't know that yeah yeah so
I don't know man I think uh uh yeah I
mean my favorite artist ever's my
favorite artist ever is yay my favorite
MC like Lyricist rapper is
Nas so Dam static or nomatic nomatic
come on it's a crazy [__] question I
I love static though that's the thing I
thought static got Braveheart party on
it feature Mary J blader is one of the
worst [__] songs in his discography
okay all right that song's so bad that
when they reprinted Stillmatic they left
it off oh [__] imagine a song sucking so
much dick that you could buy versions of
the [__] album the song it's the only
blemish on that album yeah Illmatic for
sure I prob I put it was written over
static yeah personally Love It Was
Written Jesus did you watch B bad did
you watch belly yeah okay all right
that's right yeah best worst movie ever
best worst why it's not a great movie
but it's a great
movie The thing about belly is when you
watch it as a kid you're like this [__]
is insane cuz visually it's shot so
beautifully Hype Williams killed it
exactly the story line is [__]
terrible it's kind of and nobody can act
in the whole movie like Nas is one of
the worst actors of all time they're all
playing themselves basically like right
you got t-b in there like yo I'm gonna
go to Africa
B you know what I'm saying so it's like
it's the in my opinion the best worst
movie ever it's a great take it's a
great super cinematic DMX so good that
opening scene when they [__] get the
[__] guns out of the toilet club with
the strob blade and they shoot that
[__] lady best worst movie
ever they kill methan and [__] and Boise
or whatever it was in
Nebraska methan was great dud he bites
the F he bites the [__]
banana the guy with the perm that's one
of the most like leg legendary memes of
time to me yeah yeah it's a great I mean
listen it's a very great bad movie wow I
mean you sound like me when I rip [__]
apart too so I feel you if that's how
you feel I mean I enjoy bad movies Belly
being at the top of the
list wow I [__] love I got a belly
poster on the set of my
podcast I love belly love the soundtrack
I'll just love the take on it that's a
good like honest realization about like
a movie that you like super [__] love
as a kid yeah we just did The Wedding
Singer the other day so great great well
I mean look I mean that was such a
[__] like '90s 2000s oh I just love
the mo no I love the movie we're just
talking about howy you want to know what
a [__] great movie that no one talks
about what go right now Can't Ban this
Zan oh yeah where he's the Jewish
hairdresser the hairdresser yeah with
the blow dryer on the cover right he's a
short movie that's never come up on this
and little N I don't watch it that much
little nck one of our last guest is his
favorite movie mhm hey the [__]
cartoon was good the Christmas cartoon
oh talking about Eight Crazy Nights
Eight Crazy Nights was Sol yeah Eight
Crazy Nights tight we're going to go see
Adam salor next week oh he's in town
right Y in Anaheim Anaheim what's he
doing is he going to sing yeah I saw him
in New York last year I didn't even
think about that I just assum comedy he
had his album comedy albums remember his
old comedy albums it's just that
Hanukkah song Piece of [__] Car he used
to have this goat Piece of [__] Car the
goat I went to a rock and roll concert
yeah exactly I remember I had that album
The go I was my aunt would play it
pepper that's older than us so I was
like goat can talk Chris Farley's
talking beating the sh out the goat it's
just a good it's just good overall is
that album on Spotify I don't know but
we should all listen to it the goat's
funny I'm [__] I might have to take my
wife she loves Adam Sandler you should
get tickets right now are they sold out
right now go out and after because we
got them two nights ago and there was
like 40 left oh yeah it's over I'm about
to overpay but Sandler's that guy oh
yeah I saw Sandler's not like gonna do a
lot of shows you know he plays a lot of
pickup basketball and oversized shorts
but he's not g to do a lot of shows he's
always matching it's like you were
saying like how many times do you have a
chance to see these guys that's why I
went I had to I did that I just went and
saw Metallica like a month ago and I was
like yeah I should go before they get
too old yeah that's a lot of people
right now like I want I love Metallica I
still I didn't get to see system of it
down cuz I had Co oh we went like we all
went last year I was I had tickets oh
yeah we all went last year amazing it
was sick with corn right yeah I [__]
love corn too [__] it was so tight and
they're from Glendale MH yes they're
well yeah mainly this whole entire area
and what did you say like North
Hollywood yeah where the Valley North K
little Armenia oh yeah North Kingsley
Street yeah exactly little Armenia yeah
yeah sho's cool he's been on the shows
yeah he's dope oh I saw him on the show
yeah he's awesome yeah yeah dude um sick
for sure he's yo [__] um [__] Serge
tanken is on a very weird song right now
my boy just sent me a link wait which
one is it I'll show you cuz I got a DM
to me it's like what's some chick and
he's like singing like it just sounds
[__] very random dude oh sorry I
talking about he just covered a he just
covered a song what was it Serge he just
covered a song where he was like like yo
you can't be dropping N Balls like it's
in the song oh this [__] right here look
[Music]
what
Opera
Zordon it's just very strange very Chris
Isaac sounding it's just very like uh it
just sounds it's a non-binary song for
sure you know like if that song didn't
have a gender and had blue hair you'd be
like yep yep
I get
it
[__] y we were just talking about it
yeah you can say whatever you want again
it's almost coming back man I'm telling
you we're about to be saying sweet hooks
yeah I don't know man I don't know if
it'll ever get back no it's going to
we're getting there I just was watching
[__] a pay-per-view from like 97 on
peacock and I was like Jesus amazing
times wrestling used to be crazy the
first time I said The Dudley boys mhm
the I didn't was it ECW they were in I
think originally they were in ECW right
where you can take cheese graders to the
Head the first time I ever I was a WWF
fan so I'm like yeah man so cold and I
get to ECW and they're talking [__] to
the crowd yeah ACW was Hardcore bad no
like I thought it was part of the ACT no
he was just saying horrible [__] to the
crowd and then cheese graded
somebody IED my [__] finger once
chees
graters cheese grater [__] sucks as a
as a tool I don't L one in my house
cheese graters are useless they're
stupid and they're stressful and then
you end up slipping you get too close
you [__] and then it's just it's just
like a lot of like real elbow work that
is like this she a knife it just it just
feels like they have they not figured
out the cheese greater upgrade like
pencil sharpener penc sharpener type of
why isn't there something on Prime day
that's like electric that gra cheese
like a coffee grinder just you throw in
the chunk of cheese and it just cheeses
it yo top 10 to to top 10 products on
Amazon man this is what happens here I
like this I got a different one for you
uh so last time he came back from your
podcast he brought back um I don't know
if it was gu at the whole bag no I
didn't yet I just top got oh that's
right that's right that's right it was
something else so thank you for that
those were pretty awesome it's hard for
for me to feel anything I have to like
play this stupid game with produ I mean
this is the thing right like I have a
shroom gummy brand
allegedly love that
for um not psychedelic shrooms of course
you know like the kind that like you
pizza and [__] vitamins crini
nonetheless in the mushroom Market that
is legal not the illegal because Dums a
cut and he just vetoed the bill cuz he's
a [__] slick-haired little prick when
did this happen like two days ago he
banned Skittles and vetoed the
Psychedelic bill on the same day saw
that there's no more skitt you can't eat
Skittles anymore after in I think in
three
months they're going to they have to
remove four ingredients and actually am
not mad at that CU America's food is
[__] it's bad the Skittles and candy
in other countries tast it doesn't have
it tastes like it's like Coca-Cola have
you ever had a kit cat from another
country no real CH I never have a real
chocolate I've had the green one the
green one I had too the green tea the
Asian the chocolate one from but I got
it my homie got it from Japan fire I
didn't feel all nasty go to they got a
store in the bbang mall that's like
where they sell anime figures I know
exactly what you're talking about that's
that's the John from sis of a down
that's his store what he owns the store
the news toy store in the in the mall
yeah that's his store sick where is
Topanga also you know the there's a in
Glendale right over the freeway there's
a new toy store a huge toy store that's
his store store too H yeah he he's into
Collectibles and [__] speaking of mhm
yeah I bought some [__] over oh any back
I was talking about mush uh mushrooms oh
[__] of the pizza sort of of Caris they
can be extremely uh in consistent with
their dosing usually if you get like a
chocolate bar or something um and also
they use like [__] up like when they
break it down to the m what is it's um I
don't to get into it too much we're
talking about pizza but our [__] is
extremely we test we we test everything
and we individually dose every Gummy so
it is consistent and it's hidden oh
that's amazing wow that can't be easy to
do I don't know some yeah some uh little
lady does it I'm sure or the [__]
bakery that we pay little lady does it
it's a lady I'm sure I hope so how far
back does your relationship with uh shs
go um not too far back I did them in
high school one time how was that go it
was cool uh it was it was like it it
wasn't anything too crazy it was it was
it was at um a
[__] not homecoming whatever one of
them other stupid ass things were the
the things the kids went to dance
whatever it was cool um then I got into
eat like I didn't get into eating weed I
don't want to say that cuz I hate eating
weed but then I got I got when I started
like when I ate weed as maybe I was like
Oh you mean Edibles Edibles okay so I
thought you eating weed I'm thinking
eating weed no Edibles [__] suck dude
why cuz you don't get no they're just
they're too aggressive for me oh say the
opposite okay good they're too
aggressive I got some [__] so like that
[__] kind of threw me I had some bad
experiences with Edibles that kind of
made me not want to eat anything let
alone psychedelic stuff and then like
honestly I would say like
2016 17
which wasn't that long ago you know I'm
listening to Joe Rogan talk about this
[__] on every [__] podcast right I
know and I'm like maybe I should give
these another shot yeah really Sold the
World on [__] psychedelics 1 million
per. still hasn't sold me on DMT yeah no
thank you you can keep extremely I'm
extremely stressed like I feel like DMT
would be gnarly but I'm super
scared super scared yeah cuz my friend
did it I was supposed to do it once with
my boy John John in the bay uh and then
he was like yo I did it last week and I
live 6
months oh that sucks he's like I got a
new job I got a girl like I was going on
dates and [__] like he's like I was gone
for six months in 15 minutes D see I
don't want to be gone for six months you
know that's a lot nah but I do want to
do it but no but on the mushrooms tip
like I just Joe Rogan and then I started
to [__] with him and I was like oh this
this is dope you know and then a friend
of mine is a
uh a grower of certain stuff and uh one
of my closest friends uh and we decided
like hey man like we eat this [__] and I
would always have these bad really bad
experiences with chocolates either they
would suck or they' make me sick cuz
they like chocolate like these guys
aren't sealing chocolate bars properly
and just upset my stomach or I'd go
somewhere and I'd have melted chocolate
on my [__] pants so I was like yo
like let's do some gummies you know and
the gummies are you know they're good so
we eat them do you go pretty deep with
them I would imagine oh yeah yeah I've
ate a whole bag how much is in one bag
it's a eighth that's the most that's the
most I've ever ate is eighth I haven't
gone any above haven't done the heroes
do the Ralph Barbosa the comedian on and
he [__] shocked he straight up goes
my like the one time I was do 10
gram the capsules the chocolates the
this the that the he said him his home
just had a [__] and just yeah I've only
done 3.5 and and Jes and I was in I was
in a hot tub for like nine hours wait I
think you told me about it was [__]
sick yeah oh T and paa yeah so I've been
sens gone home and got it I got it all
uh the ones you were talking abouten if
you're ever going to get [__] up
listen to let it happen by T and
Paulo do mushrooms it's a group well one
guy one guy it's one guy it's a one man
band it's like it's it's sick music he
has he has a song it's like8 and a half
minute song called let it happen and
it's one of the greatest songs ever
created and if you're really [__]
high you're gonna love it dude dude I'm
going to this it's good I like the music
what's the name t and P they hadline
well he headlin Coachella once oh so
it's a bunch of sick ass music all this
[__] and then turns out he does all the
music himself records all the
instruments he's a producer yeah yeah
yeah and then when he performs live he
just has people playing his [__] what
the [__] wow that's cool I thought it
was a bunch of fools sounds like it's
very gnarly music bro it's like great
music it's like [__] just float away or
to on drugs like if you're going to get
abducted it's good that's probably what
it sound like oh okay cool I need that
cuz I don't know I don't know any other
music than what I know I know I've only
really tripped one good time and I sat
there and just laughed Mar and a did
nothing to him two more Grands did
nothing to him of what weer good ass
mushrooms oh you're crazy raw no no was
little the one of them was
we ate raw mushrooms and you did nothing
to you so they're starting to like uh
there's like new strains of shrooms um
that are very
strong and uh they're
aggressive yeah there's some [__] called
mckas oh that sounds bomb there's some
[__] the bluey Vuitton and now blue
Vuitton and now they got now they have
super Apes which is like an albino penis
envy but like twice as strong and yeah
that should have [__] it but the thing
is is if you like get stuff well I mean
this is your podcast which is already
demonetized I'm like being very careful
about saying like certain words we
appreciate that no I feel you thank you
God no but you guys are demonetized so
[__]
it
[Laughter]
was I just had to get that off real
quick I just saw something on a Tik Tok
that proves just point
anyway how did Tower 7 fall bro that's
what I want to [__] know
anyway the shroom game is interesting if
you're selling shrooms at a
alleged like wholesale type of level for
example if you wanted to make chocolate
bars then you would probably want to buy
the variation of albino penis envy
that's twice as strong as the normal one
because then you can make 2 lbs worth of
[__] with half of the
work Mak sense which is what a lot of
guys are doing right now smart like yo
this [__] is so strong we don't have to
use you know yeah math not
meth meth not math is how my family was
raised oh I say mine too but also I'm
trying to stay on the other
path math not math you're from Merced MH
and for whatever random
reason I had to go to B I know
Bakersfield and Merced are not near each
other for the record but just a
random cuz you were your your stepdad
was like a biker Nazi dude yeah kind of
okay it was just random because like I
drove to Bakersfield twice in a month I
went there to see jelly roll and then I
went there to see uh it took my son to
go to NXT WWE [__] and both times tons
of uh of ha's out there huh the Hell's
Angels are just outside in the middle of
California they don't care no it's it
was kind of cool cuz I was like I
stopped to get gas and there was like 12
biker dudes and I was like oh [__] oh
yeah of course I didn't know oh sorry I
thought you meant like you're going to
like restaurants she like Dam there's
gangs everywhere no they at the gas hell
yeah no I'm just saying like I just was
like oh this is like there's a a lot of
bikers a lot lot of them lot of in the
valley a lot but [__] Bakersfield was
lit I was uh getting gas coming back
from Merced speaking of bikers I stopped
this in some spot I think Hanford or
some [__] and there was like 50 bikers
but very rare I don't see a lot of all
Black Gang biker dudes but I went damn
all you fools are big as got beard you
look like the regular white biker dud
it's just not white it blew my mind bro
there was 60 deep damn yeah no there's
like um like on Harley's like they were
chilling they have like a we I forget
there there's like a version of Sturgis
that's like for black biker gangs I
forget where it's at oh is there that
[__] looks crazy oh see I had never
really seen that before shout out to
Sturgis man it sounds like a sounds like
a scary place to be man yeah you know
what's crazy is them old dudes are still
[__] like crazy right so it's like
you got to understand like what a old
what old biker [__] got to be like it's
almost like [__] a jugal you know
what I'm saying like a juglet you know
it's like it's like you guys ever ever
see somebody and you're like someone
[__] them you're lost you know what's
going on but jugal jugal are ICP fans oh
okay okay all the girls at chug Mountain
dude with dir ass feet at the store
imagine like the old biker dudes going
to Sturges like they're 60 they've
probably had been had herpes for like
three decades or something like
and they're going there CU they're going
to [__] somebody they're going to party
they're going to do hard drugs and then
they're going to have sex the old guys
sound dope but what do the women look
like like that and what's the [__]
smell like these are the questions that
need to be
answered yeah they they don't look like
Peg Bundy and Sons of Anarchy guys I
tell those aren't the kind of old
ladies it's so crazy that they used her
of all people and she [__] did you
watch that show yes I watched that show
when [__] pig Bundy stabbed [__]
Jack teller's girl in the head with a
[__] Fork that dirty [__] did we
just talk about Sons of Anarchy today
with you was that earlier great show
we're talking about the only time they
ever get to men said well you can still
go you you can go still get it get it
taken care of but only in mered County
he's talking to one of the girls like
what that's all the love we get all
right yeah you can commit murder over
there man don't worry about it it was
wild it was
wild um so back I guess to something
that was not horrible moment to talk
about one of our sponsors and this is my
bookie whether it's UFC baseball
football or basketball make sure you're
betting with my bookie do us a favor
right now click the link in the
description no matter what platform
you're watching the link in the
description follow that bet $50 and
you're going to get $200 instantly
credit to your account bet 50 get 200
back even if you lose that 50 you at
least you got the $200 credit listen to
what I'm saying guys it's a win-win
win-win situation also UFC 294 October
21st is coming up go ahead and bet right
there Marty and I we're going to go
spend some money even if it's just fun
to watch the fights and hope you win you
forget you could possibly win a bunch of
money too that's one thing we didn't
consider I know it's betting but it's
like it's more fun than anything slot
games live casino table games there's
much more than just betting on sports
but remember if you're going to bet
anything anywhere anytime make sure it's
with my bookie once again click the link
in the description bet 50 bucks that
first deposit 50 bucks you automatically
get $200 credit to your account once
again shout out to my bookie thank you
for watching what's up guys taking a
moment to talk about one of our brand
new sponsors and this is borash and like
I said last time I'm super stoked about
these products because Bard hash is
actually the facility that they get
manufactured my homie runs that spot one
of my close friends and he's been
telling me about this brand for months
and then I finally saw them and tried
them and now they're a sponsor this one
right here is GMO and inside this box it
explains fully what live resin is so
when you get these at the store you can
actually see every single thing about it
so these right here are their pods these
are the little pods right here the pens
so if you're on Instagram go ahead and
follow [__] let them know the dope as
usual podcast sent you they have Edibles
and these are [__] Edibles so in
these there's grape strawberry orange
lemon and blue raspberry 100 mg for the
entire bag 10 Mig a piece so thank you
so much for supporting the brands that
support us thank you to board
hash
it tastes [__] awesome rip
Selena and Selena and rip to Selena the
only thing when people I know it's the
fattest [__] you ever heard I when
people say Selena I go yeah damn yeah
she's a good singer and then immediately
after I think of Selena the movie when
they're eating those pepperonis I'm like
damn wasn't every pie that sounds you
know I've watched I've watched bits and
pieces of the Selena movie like a
hundred times never seen the whole thing
but I've never sat I mean my wife is
Mexican my son's mom is
Mexican I've seen the Selena all
together in Parts but yeah I don't
understand the scene it's like marrying
like a Mexican lady marrying it's like
her and she's like yo I've seen the
Christmas story bits and pieces 80 times
M cuz that's like the white culture
movie and Selen is the Mexican culture
movie but I've seen it 900 times but in
pieces on Christmas Selena is a great
movie though it is but those pet those
PE J JLo Fly Girls the woman that killed
Selena got out she's out on Earth is she
out she just got out how did you get out
she like walked out with like a UFC F
[__] weird it was like she's out of jail
someone
d edit that out no we just bleep it we
don't got to edit it out it was said
don't even mute his mouth just bleep the
sound so people can still read I just
let that fly so you guys to demonetized
huh so let's talk about this war thing
going on Jesus Christ so you're
demonetized let's talk
about Jesus Christ might had to bleep
all that [__] [__] my no for real my
homie does twitch yeah smokes hell weed
does Hell stuff said one thing about
what's going on there he is baned Adam
why I completely banned off twitch over
what's happening right now that seems
really wrong he say I have no idea but
I'm not going to say it but I'm going to
say this we won't even go there yeah
let's not even go there cuz we care
she's out right no uh 2025 oh sorry
she's getting out or a hoax or some [__]
cuz I saw I saw the same thing I saw the
same uh story about it it was weird yeah
I saw that too that's why I said she's
out that's pretty crazy how do you get
out for kill killing somebody I don't
know hey guess what I have two uncles
one passed
away is a
competition so I didn't know what you
really go with so my uncle on my mom's
side went to jail he went to prison for
murdering his wife and got out he got
out and like he didn't do that much time
cuz he was on peyote oh so psychosis
like a manslaughter thing so he killed
his wife oh that's sad was he sad about
it at least no Oho he committed murder
on purose
you should have testified like yo he
blocked the [__] on my space I promise
I I honestly never cuz that sh happened
so far before I was alive I never oh I
never really dived into his thought on
the dead lady you know you know him yeah
he's dead talk to him yeah yeah my mom's
you like hey man what's what's wrong
with you he stay away from us so yeah so
he got out uh then my uncle Rocky killed
his best friend in
Texas and got hit with Mass Slaughter he
was high as
[__] and then ended up being a
millionaire who owns drug rehabs so the
moral story is if you MK somebody you go
get some meth and just get as high as
you can until the cops get there and you
can get out because that both sounds
like what we said is Qui privilege
because that sounds crazy how do you get
out of priv all they all each each of
these incidents happened in the like
late 70s early 70s somewhere in that
somewhere in the uh range of age yeah
probably 7 like six or something 78 78
so when your power was Stronger is what
I'm hearing yeah so like like life like
you killed that guy you guys are going
to jail that's what happened that sounds
insane yeah no murderer uncles on on
each side of my family and like I'm
really close to my uncle Rocky like he's
oh damn he is your family wild as hell
overall or are they just okay I got a
crazy family man my family is [__]
terrible in a good I mean they're
terrible man you try to save it yeah I
like so you have brothers or sisters
just one sister she's great she's great
parents are fine
now but yeah like my uncles my aunts my
grandma my
[__] um all my cousins like at a
certain point in time in the Arizona
prison system one of my cousins ran the
[__] Aryan Nation at at the prison he
was in he was one of the shot haulers
and the other one was a shot caller for
the Mexican Mafia in the same prison
they're the same age they grew up
together committing crimes together one
is the most hardest chorus looking half
meex controller you've ever seen in your
life and the other one is just the
whitest [__] alive so they ended
up [__] like at war with each other
in prison even though they were cousins
but you know yeah well that sucks yeah
these [__] was doing some
[__] up [__] man like my cousin Aaron
who was in the Aron Nation dude they
made him do some foul [__] he said that
he had to boil they boil piss and
[__] and they poured they poured it on
somebody mhm scars you y I mean in more
than one way yeah you might you might
catch like some real oh diseases off
that yeah yeah it's a open wound being
scolded by [__] by parasites let's heat
up this parasite stuff let's heat up
this [__] white this [__] white
trash racist [__] [__] full of
Mountain Dew and beef and
hatred let's pour some of this hatred in
your in your open burnt [__] wound yo
um yeah cuz like I said my stepdad so
much stuff about the uh prison system it
sucks but that that's a doozy that's one
he's told me about many times or they
the I don't know how deep we're going to
get into
Stu but like the same thing like [__]
like put it on a knife let it dry for a
couple days so when you stab full they
get infected instantly
like you guys in your room it's just in
your room plotting on this type of [__]
like yo what's in your bed just some
[__] then some of the riot stories these
guys were telling me were crazy like
some of those prison rats [__] nuts
bro gargoyles I mean gargoyles
Gladiators it's really like some
gladiator [__] and then they'll take
note if you don't put no work in in a
riot like they'll like take note that
you didn't do [__] and you just ducked
off
[__] GH Every Time I Think of prison R I
think of do you ever remember Natural
Born Killers of course yeah great movie
that's when I think of prison riot when
that one goes south yeah Tommy Lee
Jones a wild that was a wild movie have
you seen this natural it's with Woody
harelson and um that chick and that
chick that
chick um but yeah good movies man yo so
we have talked about a bunch of random
[__] since we've been here I couldn't
even tell you what we talked about
mainly no this comes out 7-Eleven don't
worry about that mainly 911 and Alex
Jones have you ever interviewed him or
anything that' be way he left I don't
want my [__] I give my channel
deleted dude yeah just saying his name
together is a key trigger I I I um I
think he's wildly entertaining yes but
he's also got like he's a crazy person
but also some of the [__] he said of the
'90s has end up coming true it's like
yo
yep cuz in the 90s he wasn't like going
nuts going too crazy because he dialed
it back I didn't realize he was around
in the '90s he went to the Bohemian
Grove and got footage 9s the Bohemian
Grove is this place in Northern
California where all these rich people
who run the world all meet up and
ritual with this giant owl he [__]
snuck in and there's footage on YouTube
from the 9s it's official and then he
asked that [__] old [__] dumb with
eyes [__] looking [__] that
was always on see and then he went up to
him and he was like cuz he knew that the
guy was a part of the bohemian something
club and he asked the dude about the
Bohemian Grove Alex Jones just ran up on
the street and the dude got [__]
shook he's like I think it's very rude
that you would ask me about that this a
private it's [__] crazy butan Grove
is Alex Jones been on the [__] for 30
years and then he's over there worried
about Joey Diaz talking about his
dick what oh I don't know about that you
seen the clip where Joey Diaz realizes
that he's not live on air it's Joe Rogan
Joey Diaz Alex Jones sitting over here
and he goes all right so you know this
is going to be on the internet we're off
the radio and then Joey Diaz does not
stop STP he goes we're on the radio oh
[__] and he just starts talking
about how he weed in his dick folds and
talking about a bunch of crazy [__]
under his dick under his balls and he he
goes nuts yeah I love it yeah yeah you
Alex Jones is a crazy person that is
extremely like when he's on like
flagrant 2 with Andrew scholes or Joe
Rogan it's so fun like there was a
episode where what's the dude who who's
Joe Rogan's friend who teaches MMA Bravo
Eddie Bravo was just trolling Alex Jones
every time he'd say something he would
just troll him and get and this dude
would get so worked up in purple like
red like it's just like it's great to
watch and know it's like it makes you
kind of wish you had like a a friend
like that you know for like
entertainment just like a fat like
alcoholic like crazy guy right that you
could just like like everybody be like
hey let's get him stirred up for dinner
huh like you know
real that was a sick giggle bro SI was
right on time
man yes uh Alex Jones has he recovered
in the world's eyes no of course there's
no coming back done he [__] they BL
him they were like paypals like bam done
and then Twitter bam over everybody he's
a [__] you know he he kind of sealed
his fate with a few of those things you
know so yeah he went a little harder on
was like but it's over now so I'm just
going to double down and say [__] you
too didn't he get sued for like a
billion
dollars he lost l so he he's streaming
six times a week bro for no for no money
yeah I mean I don't know how smart he
was in terms of like what business he
has set up and but yeah they hit him
upside the head for was it nine figures
but I know I had that much information
about [__] I would be like yo what's the
financial information I'm trying to get
rich too I think he's a [__] idiot so
he probably uh didn't think that way
he's a
dumbass he doesn't seem like he's
plotting and planning all like yeah he
knows a lot of random [__] but he's also
an idiot he's like not like Biff from
back I me he said that he said he said
that on Joe Rogan he said I don't know
if y'all know this or not but I'm
[__] he did say that he did say that
I like that yeah you want that out of a
character like him I want someone to
admit to me that they're stupid as [__]
if you're a [__] never mind if you're
a stupid
[__] I'd like you to be self-aware
just like if you're a stupid rapper who
sucks yeah be self aware M that's how
Waka Flaka came in he's like I'm not
even good at this [__] but I'm cracking
right nowy hey hey Waka Flocka actually
can rap he's from Queens he has some
songs but I'm saying when he came out on
Machine Gun Kelly [__] that was his
whole pitch that he's like I don't give
a [__] that I'm not he was popping
before Wild Boy white man come on this
guy right here all right well no listen
had [__] hard in the paint that was
right on the same time no it wasn't it
was after Walker was already lit that's
why mjk put him on the song cuz he was
[__] hot as [__] it was the same era
though it was in the same like 16 18
months sure when he came out damn you
know the months yeah I mean I was
[__] oh wait you do music all day
what theck am I talking about I do radio
four hours a day the [__] am I talking
about shout out to Flocka of the Waka
sorts
yo we should do a whole episode of
renaming
ra Flocka of the wur doctor suited me
Dre
MD the Noto
doctor Tiana doctor hey Andre I get my
teeth my dentist is there I have real
teeth by I get my
teeth my dentist is there cuz cuz I I
feel like what I was about to say would
make people think I had veneers which I
don't because obviously my teeth aren't
great so you know I hope I don't have
veneers cuz then it would really give
what you were saying some validity like
I have a Tijana doctor look at kev's F
like if that was the case and I had and
these were
veneers you would associate these shitty
teeth with veneers that someone in Tiana
was paid to do and then you wouldn't go
to Tiana to get some of the actual good
work you can get stem cells Dam right
back to stem cells
yeah but also my grandma goes to Tiana
for everything obviously great and she
brought my sister and my sister took a
video I thought you were going to say
your sister got a BBF no she was teeth
she brought my sister in my sister got a
Brazilian B no she got her teeth her
teeth worked on okay yeah and she sent
me a video of where she was getting her
teeth worked on my Grandma knows a lady
that does it from her house grandma's a
dick and it looked like or the Joker
Jack Nicholson realizes that he's white
all the time now and he starts crack it
up and Batman Returns yeah so um all bad
there's actual doctor's offices there
there are I went to them but my sister
didn't get to go to one did she not know
that going into it she went to some
lady's house they your grandma house to
my grandpa she got a cheap as [__] and
it didn't even work she has a hole on
the side of w she just laid down on the
couch she was in a chair in noas are
on like an interrogation room and she
sat I would have left I would the doctor
pulled a needle out cuz I had back neck
issues I got a quartis Zone in your
spine I went [__] no and and then I left
my grandpa got pissed in Mexico yeah I
was in Mexico I'm like put you put a
needle on my spine I can't even
speak wait they put a for the dentist no
for her I went for my neck cuz I all bad
back issues now I know he wouldn't have
fix [__] he would have made it worse but
I have hell herniated disc and he was
going to do a a cortisone shop have you
ever done steroids no why is it I'm so
buff well cuz we were talking about how
you were B you were doing like lifting
and then I thought about your hurt back
so I made the correlation and then the
random thought of has he ever done
steroids cuz I that'd be crazy if it had
no side effects and just eat them like I
had a friend who does who did them and
like he would always like talk about his
nuts with shrink and
[__] so yeah it's a weird thing to trade
off like I backne it's like holding it
and just filling up with water the rest
of your body yeah cuz like how do your
nuts actually shrink you know or body
just got bigger and it worked you just
look smaller your body got so big
everything looks
smaller I'll trade some back acne for
being [__] shredded but leave my nuts
out of
this that's what you're going to go for
you are accepting of the back acne it's
not a deal it's not a deal breaker for
you not to be shredded about the Chris
Ben wall style attitude is that a deal
breaker I'll take it I'm good on theis
wall no he killed his family yeah he
went nuts he killed everybody and then
killed himself he cripp cross faac
everyone and then Dove and or was that I
think that was probably both bunch of
stuff but he was raging and he probably
had CTE though yeah I he got [__]
[__] up with chair them chair shots
are real I've been to them I've seen
them no they're real the real chairs yes
are they like the thick ones that you
you get for the good parties or the thin
they're
metal and this is the thing no they're
normal chairs they're not like a they
might they're like the the cheap like
metal ones but they're actually like
they don't make like special chairs that
break you they're not foam oh no no I
know they're metal but like but I'm
saying like you take a shot to the head
like it's uh if you take a thousand of
those a hundred of those you're [__]
[Music]
yeah yo taable SLS chairs you take
enough hits to the head you become a
dunon you feel me so you got but also
like I still see mankind living it up
right but he's he's crushing it he limps
he's fine right but he's also like
he's scarred he's completely scared that
shrapnel all over yeah these guys
[__] cutting their foreheads open
with oh I remember all that [__] these
fools were biting razors in their
mouth what yeah they would like some
some guys would keep a razor in their
mouth to do what to keep on them so they
L on in the match and they fall they
slice themselves like let's say they're
recovering and you're bleeding you know
no thanks I was going to go get an
education at that point oh nah I'm good
on that I Swan Dive into some [__]
books after that one yeah I mean there
was a shout out to the [__] they
called him what do they call the guys
who blade themselves there's a word for
it it might be emo girls yeah Cutters
girls that listen to [__] AAL LaVine
Panic at the Disco and AAL LaVine and
what's that one Evan Ence oh remember
that the one famous video of Evan Evan
she's falling off the building the guy's
like bro that song is sick he could just
pulled her up the whole [__] video
he's like singing to her he could
have [__] and then she falls he didn't
really want to [__] save her I've
never seen EV Ence is like you remember
that vampire movie that starred the
[__] and she was wearing all black and
they did like a bunch of them it was
like a futuristic vampire movie it was
like a franchise in the 2000s and it was
a fine [__] wearing all black and she
was fighting vampires and they did like
20 of the movies
no man it's like an action think of
Blade but there's a chick I'm thinking
of Blade but I don't think of anything
else no no hold on now I'm [__] hold
on is it called Trinity something no
that's a chick from Matrix hold on it's
GNA bother me it's gon to bother me
Vampire Slayer movie
franchise action Girl star
underworld I do remember those yeah
there was like three of them the chick
with the chopped hair so I bring that
movie up because it reminds me of
evanescence I feel like this they
probably played the whole soundtrack it
should have been yeah yeah underworld
they did a lot of these movies three of
them two of them people like no no no no
they did they did more let's see they
switched to another guy
Underworld franchise movie
[Music]
franchise one two wait wait wait oh [__]
there's one two three four there's six
of them
yeah damn see know is this 03609 11 12
and
16 what the years they dropped oh I was
like what the [__] you talking about I
think you just said they were six it's a
type move with the wedding band like
I've never seen just the blacked out one
like I I can't wear one yeah been
married forever you don't wear one
that's awesome yeah so like uh I think
like a silver band is cool but it's like
it just to me looks like a old man [__]
like I feel like a a really like a
senior you know like a real dad you know
I am a real dad but like not you know
I'm like kind of like their friend how's
your oldest my kid's 18 now oh wow yeah
um but uh but yeah I saw the black and I
like the black and this [__] was like
eight bucks on
Amazon you know he throw it the it's so
it's light and and and uh the what the
ring I got married with was silver with
like a diamond in it and I was like this
[__] looks [__]
and I don't mean that in like a bad way
you mean in a South Park Way can you
bleep
that shout out to the lbgt
qzz I love y'all man this wased a little
kid when they learn their alphabets I
love them bro shout out to them bro I
respect it gang I'm an ally you're an
ally [__] yeah be fierce I am a fierce
ass fool for
sure this why H half Mexican uncles he
soundie OG size oh [__] bro I grew up
with them [__] Mexicans and then my
whole all my kids are Mexican my [__]
wife's Mexican her [__] uncle's
Mexican I would assume
so what the
[__] you imagine if her uncle was like
never
mind that we're not there yet we're not
back yet it's not
97 all right
well that was ridiculous man we've been
talking about random [__] but that's
good nothing specific nothing specific
and that's okay right next to the
Pacific to be specific is Little Rob
would say he knows next week Monday 8:30
in the morning I'm G to be talking to
little Rob in the morning 8:30 in the
morning you're doing a podcast Yeah by
your choice yeah it's cuz I train at
6:45 what do you you train what
horses I can't even get that one
off with a [__] traitor I'm [__]
exercising [__] I don't know
he's like I'm a professional racketball
player I train every morning we don't
know anything about you like
that my wishes are actors in Yellowstone
bro you could have just said owls I
might have believed you too so hold on
what kind of are we talking like uh I'm
just [__] I'm just lifting weights
with my Armenian friend
es the [__] MMA Place
yeah horses would be crazy if I had a
horse bro [__] crazy hey man my dad
used to be a cameraman at a horse track
wait so your dad's just like I'm real
good left and right bro no my I'm the
[__] my pops just sit up in a tower and
that's what I mean like I got this on
fock he didn't have any sort of previous
experience they hire him so that tells
you how hard it
was you know so I used to go to the
horse races a lot you're like OG I'm
telling you swear to God that's that's
where the gambling [__] started oh no
well that's the thing if you go to like
if you go to a horse a horse track
you'll really see what a real degenerate
it looks like we're talking like their
suits all messed up the type of man in
middle of Phoenix Arizona would go hang
out and watch horses run around and
spend money on the horses and then get
really really angry and they it just
looks
like it just looks like you know like
uh yeah just a bunch of Alex
Jones's maybe maybe maybe better dressed
red yelling johar tearing up tickets
John Goodman's a great one he's a good
favorite movie ever is Big leowski John
Goodman it's a good one it's a good
movie I did not expect him just to die
that pissed me off when I was a kid you
about Donnie yeah what the [__] man that
pissed me off his ashes in the in the
fers you never saw the big leowski you
know I [__] haven't I know it's
insane I know I haven't Mar's not a big
movie
[__] diving into [__] tables
outside I found out about
Buffalo I found out about the tables
thing from him I had no idea yeah it's
like uh you know I guess if I've been to
Buffalo no offense but it is kind of
exactly what you think it would
be so like when they say like I've been
to Detroit right and Detroit was like I
love Detroit but like what people think
Detroit is is actually what Buffalo is
I've been saying that for years oh
that's funny he makes that connection
all the time Buffalo is like Ghost Town
Detroit what you think it is but like
the rest of America's like yo Detroit ah
a mes the crime no that's buff Buffalo
Detroit's solid Detroit's on coming back
right d I [__] love Detroit I went
there for like four days and I [__]
loved it good place Buffalo was cool
though you know yeah sounds like you had
a great time I ate great pizza uh I
gambled a little and uh went to the mall
uh what were you uh recording I recorded
a bunch of content with Conway and and
uh gun out there and uh yeah I mean it
was a buffalo you
know there was [__] food what month
was it there was [__] food I went to
this place called uh something Corner
something's Corner West Side gun got a
song named after it something's corner
it's a a restaurant that's where I have
my wings there cuz I was like I need
buffalo wings you know like so he took
me to this uh this corner some someone's
corner it's a restaurant there this
[__] old ass white lady in there
she's cooking she's serving drinks she's
smoking she's making wings them shit's
were solid [__] and then there's another
place that we went to that was like kind
of like
a Caribbean fast food restaurant it was
like independent they had like empanadas
and [__] in there it's been like 10
years for me I don't know these new
spots I don't know we're going to go
back soon I know that yeah but Buffalo's
lit I mean it's not but you know I like
the we got the bills we got grisela
we're better than we a long time right I
like the [__] comp no never
mind two of the three guys don't even
live there they live in Atlanta yeah
that should we found out found out
recently yes only guy who stuck around
was
Conway still there [__] it's cold go to
Atlanta this strip Clos yeah what what
month were you there I was actually
there in December and it wasn't terrible
nice they said like we got the most
random time like where it wasn't like it
was like cold but it wasn't like freeze
over see my breath come out cold not
that bad at all that might have been
that bad but it wasn't like there was no
snow was weed legal while you're there
was it like nice it actually that's
what's crazy about the weed [__] in New
York if you go to New York City I've
never seen it is truly ridiculous cuz
New York used to be the hardest place to
smoke at like cops are treated like
crack you know or the you're going into
jail for weed in New York and then
within a day it became the most like
liberal weed city in the United States
that's what I told him you could go
smoke in front of cops there's I mean
you there's just fold up tables on the
corner they're just roll and people are
just rolling up everywhere at a
restaurant I told you I saw people roll
if you go to like any of those bodegas
like not any of them but I went three of
the bodegas we went into were selling
shrooms and Ace yeah
openly right they're on the front with
the packages on the fu crazy so New York
is like yeah it's very different it's
like the twi on compared to how it used
to be mhm so shout out to New York man
yeah they got some pretty sick sessions
there too super though sketch the S you
know how they got oh the we [__] I heard
I heard super sketching new like in
middle of Manhattan there's just a
[__] building front with no sign and
then you got to know some keyword got to
bring you in oh God crazy it's like uh W
West but it's like uh LA California 2015
14 yeah you do the same [__] out here
buy a sticker for 50 and you can get an
eighth for my friend for free mhm that's
how you to sell a to people really yeah
the sticker's 50 bucks that weed looks
great you like I would love that weed
you want to buy the sticker give the
weed away yeah this is free if you buy a
sticker that's so fire that's how they
used to do it yeah so like you'd be like
here's a $100 t-shirt mhm oh here yeah
or that's not I mean I mean on some
trash we yeah for sure right but that's
how they used to do it that's how they
used to do mixtapes too yeah yep I used
to do well I used to provide I used to
wholesale mixtapes as a kid to little
shops and they to
not because it was illegal to
technically sell music that is burnt
copyrighted oh cuz all the mixtapes are
these thin Jewel cases and they always
said for promotional use only mhm so you
legally couldn't sell them so you would
have to buy the sticker and you get a
mixtape yeah that's how I got Kanye [__]
I'm good really
yeah yeah like uh I used to sell
mixtapes the swap meat and burnt CDs and
jerseys and purses and oh you were a
hustle little kid yeah so I got the name
bootle Kev I was selling bootleg [__] in
there yeah I guess but yeah I used to I
mean of face [__] I used be the [__]
mixtape guy too so yeah we used to like
have all those and then I would always
keep something like some sort of little
sign or something that like when never
like we would always have Sheriff's walk
through and like have people break down
their table cuz they were selling like
fake [__] purses whatever and early on
like when I first started selling
mixtapes like I never got in trouble by
the police but then once they like the
label started to make a big stink of it
then these [__] cops would walk
through the [__] swap me and if you
were selling mixtapes they would make
you pack up and they'd [__] find you
so end of that yeah I switch to a fake
NFL
jerseys did you have a on the bottoms
though o could you tell there this was
early though so this was before everyone
had fake NFL jerseys cuz now if you go
on eBay you go anywhere you get a
[__] add on your eye juice like
$39.99 Jersey that's usually $200 cuz
it's [__] fake I love going to NFL
games now everyone has fake jerseys on
damn not everybody but there's so many
just just treacherously horrible fake D
I used to sell these things but I sold
them before the secret was out so I was
I would buy them for 20 from uh this
little Chinese lady on I would get on a
MSN Messenger video with her she would
show me stuff I'd be like y let me see
that let me see what the charger Jersey
looks like all so I put my order in and
then little Asian lady will send that
[__] over 20 at Jersey I'd sell them for
like
150 on Amazon or some [__] just the
human beings you the
people the radio station I get people
some orders and [__] did they know they
were fake no
now they do I mean now they do that's a
long time ago everybody knows about fake
jerseys now whatever but you the Hall of
Fame jerseys those sick ones all the
fake Mitchell and S jerseys and [__] oh
you had the tags on them yeah well
that's what's crazy is like yeah I mean
dude I think that was around let's see
whatever year that was like ' 05 06 so
that was like
LT um I would sell his jersey a lot
Adrien Peterson I was like that was that
era yeah 2003 it's like
056 say LT Lan Thompson was booming
around them though LT was fire it was a
[__] I those those Chargers jerseys were
fly too when they first came out like
the almost purple bluish ones yeah I
remember that [__] shout to the the
[__] Chargers no one cares about them
anymore I said that the other day like
no one in La is a Chargers fan not one
Chargers fan is here in Los Angeles
nobody is rocking a Chargers jersey and
they have the more promising quarterback
like obviously the Rams just won a Super
Bowl but if I'm like an LA person and I
gotta invest in the team I'm G invest in
the team Justin Herbert's the [__]
quarterback
of [__] the
Rams they share stadiums now right they
what do they share the stadium yeah that
sucks they've got like the same colors
damn near I mean Sofi is gorgeous um
you've been to the the Raiders one in
Vegas I have not been inside I heard
it's nice it's bomb the thing I got me
I'll say this one more thing I got from
my seat to my car and
out in 15 minutes that's impressive cuz
they block off all the traffic for like
a half a mile around the whole stadium
so everyone can just [__] leave and
there's like 30 parking lots little on
oh that's great it was bomb I I can had
a joint lit by the time I Rosie was
driving yeah by the time I was already
like out of where the security guards
were
wow yeah it's the best thing go there
get drunk drunk and Uber back who'd you
see I saw the Raiders
play I think it was the Chargers this
like a year ago it's it's a division
game [__] was tight see you know about
that oh you fantasy football I don't
know divisions I don't know the a I just
know teams and people and I know West I
never got any of that sh even I was
playing football I'm like what zone [__]
you I'm go for the ball I'm the nose
tackle I don't need know Zone
left or right like where are we shifted
left or right you're nose tackle yeah
soone like I don't even know that [__]
it's a serious position it's just like
crush this for and [__] concussion
yeah CT and then I was uh the center so
I started both so I knew what he was
thinking like I just played that [__] 10
minutes ago but yeah no um I played it
oh the long story the only [__] time
I ever got a sack almost damn near cuz I
would instantly in and Chase the fool
and I'm not going to to catch the
quarterback but I run him right in the
outside linebacker always I'm always
half tackle and the one time I [__]
was gonna murder this man and he was the
guy everybody talked about I hit him and
he hit tossed me and threw my ass it was
Colin Kaepernick I it was Colin
Kaepernick he played right by me that's
the only time wait you almost sacked
Colin Kaepernick I was a kid we were we
were 15 wait wait so and no it turned
out to be Colin C cuz I hit this wait
wait wait you almost sacked Colin
Kaepernick I hit him and bro I was
benching I was lifting weights and this
full did
this like I wasn't [__] we had to watch
tape we never watched tape ever we had
to watch tape on this kid and I said he
looks like the the Zer seed fool from
300 he's just like a big tall brown kid
yeah I was like that's exactly what he
is [__] this kid he [__] and then I hit
him then he ran 80 yards and we lost the
only loss of the Season cuz I miss the
fu tackle wow then watching the NFL
draft and I was like from Turlock I'm
like Turlock and they show his picture
I'm like that's the [__] kid and then
he got drafted for the ners so I always
say like yo he better be the NFL that
that's NFL and he was so maybe feel less
it made me feel less dumb is he coming
back never I don't think anybody let him
back it's not even about letting it you
think he can't play at a certain point
in time it was about they didn't want
him in obviously but I think at this
point I think I think now I think he's
34 yeah something like that right so you
gotta think like he hasn't played in
seven years but work he's still in shape
though it doesn't matter if you haven't
played in seven years and you're 34 and
you're a football team are you going to
take a chance on him who could play the
position he's unknown you don't know if
he still got it or you going to take a
chance on somebody who's like been
actively playing the last seven years or
you know you don't think one person will
take a chance on him no I think if he
was smart he'd go to the XFL and pro
everybody could play would you like to
see it though I would I would love it
mhm if he was smart he'd go play for the
Rocks League cuz they have a partnership
with the NFL and show him up and show
that he can still
play show these [__] you can
still you got or other idea he runs I
run and if I can take him down he should
not be playing in the NFL anymore how
about that or if I can get a hand on him
you're out come on to show you guys arm
wrestle shut the [__] up you could be
like bro I almost sacked you it's like
you're the fat kid I shook like that was
me man he probably shook a lot of fat
kids to be fair no to be honest like
that was the only game we lost of the
Season that was the only you guys were
really good yeah we were the [__] and
then I hit him and he didn't it's like I
wasn't there he hit you it's like when
kids are on your leg you're like get the
[__] off of me it's exactly what he did
to me anyway that was the end of it
that's the only time that I ever thought
I was going to be tight and I
wasn't yeah you got the story forever
yeah nobody believes me they don't
believe you hell people don't like bro
just look where he went to school we
made football against each other it
shows it [__] idiot yeah I don't care
anyway yeah man we're going to go ahead
and get you out of here thank you for
being here end on that random ass story
where can everybody find your show and
where can find your Instagram your I
just just just go on YouTube Type in
bootle cab go on Spotify wherever you
find your podcast needs uh just type my
name and it'll pop up and then uh the
radio shows everywhere not everywhere
it's in a lot of places and it's every
day Monday through Friday Monday through
Friday and you said 700 to 11: at night
no that's just in La some places I do
morning some places I do afternoons it's
not all the same oh yeah that schedule
sounds ter is it a club in yeah I want a
club in yeah oh what is it what is it
called 1111 1111 in Scottdale in
Scottsdale Arizona cool up and then uh
so the nightclub you always hosting with
all these fools that's your
Club that's like yo I grow all this
wheed you guys want to buy wheed yeah
come on over I don't go any weed I'm
just saying that's the exact same thing
like I provide it all please I'll play
your
record yeah so uh got the club um my
Instagram is bootle Kev you can follow
me what
else 16-year-old you walks in and he's
like fool I'm G beat your ass are you
going to beat his ass he's going to beat
your ass oh I [__] up there we go I [__]
up my 16-year-old self for sure I was
[__] but he's got mad Jersey money
though but I was SK bro like like a rail
like it took me so long to like hit a
wall like with metabolism in life and it
was like barely like you know four years
ago I could eat anything
now I could get pudgy if I wanted
to it's a good skill to
have you have it no no no I have the one
that just it's a stagnant one oh it's
just there not the good one if I want to
like if you wanted to lose weight you
could yeah I'm slowly getting there yeah
yeah good [__] he's fixing us spine
first yeah is it is it because it I mean
obviously it's probably harder for you
to work out right you be too active like
you can't lift weights cuz you're back
well what it is is like I'd be working
out I had a trainer for three months and
every day I'm like we can't wait my back
oh so every day you'd be just in pain
all day every day my back hurts so and
then I went to the doctor and then they
found like yo your spine is broken you
need to fix it so I've been getting I
would go five times a week to this
doctor damn so what did what did was it
uh it was the bodybuilding no I was just
a wait in I did the the mve moving for
15 years with my family and then I've
been sitting for 8 years editing and
then Marty took over the editing yeah it
just my back sucks but I'm fixing that
[__] they're like yo you're going to be
in a wheelchair full hurry up so we're
fixing it now good [__] yeah yeah we're
going to be all right look like Mario
Lopez I see it but Mario Lopez in Save
By the Bell minus the hair I see it yeah
it's going to be sick I'm going be 50
going extra extra popping hey what's up
guys looking High [__] great he's old
he's like 55 I'm saying that
[__] he's all rocked and [__]
yeah he's a he's a gorgeous guy pause
he's a gorgeous guy pause I don't know
you say PA then you just let that one
slide everybody goes yeah it's Mario
Lopez bro Mario Lopez is beautiful
specimen Mario Lopez it's funny we we
were at dinner last night I'm like look
at this Mario Lopez ass looking waiter
he pulls all these [__] my thing
about Mario Lopez is like does you think
he's like uh like how does he is it
surgery is it Botox is it the face yeah
he does some work on that this this he
just looks like a like like a Kendall
but maskin yeah he works out all day
every day when we smoke weed he's like
I'm going to do 10050 push-ups real
quick you know why they're paying the
[__] out of me he's just in such good
shape and it's cuz he's working you ever
seen Nip Tuck he was in Nip Tuck he's
like why you eat breakfast I'm running
10 miles morning yo one know what's
crazy about nip tuck it was really good
it was and then they're like when move
to Hollywood I'm [__] over this show
bro first like three or four seasons
heat he episode was like wait this guy
first epod was crazy wa wa I'm 14 I was
like w [__] wait wasn't the first
episode didn't it yes he pulled that
girl at the thing like I'm a surgeon and
hits her with the car didn't it did it
have anything Christian Troy did it have
anything to do with them fixing like
being forced to fix a mafia or a cartel
guy face that was later on that was
later on and the assistant came in that
[__] was crazy show it's a good ass show
Marty you probably shouldn't watch it
like you have your kids around it's it's
good I had them all on DVD damn yeah you
really like that
[__] earned his [__]
name oh were they real no I bought them
I bought oh you bought them okay I have
them all burned yeah n they were legit
how do you feel when someone bootlegs
some of your [__] bootlegs what [__]
anything you put out like oh it's my
radio so you can't be bootlegging my own
[__] hard to do that I mean I mean like
um I think they can get it we already
have people bootlegging the shrooms and
I don't give a [__] um the
like when people take my YouTube stuff
and put it on their Channel I don't care
either like whatever it's just free
promotion I just think it's kind of
funny yeah someone starts steal start
making fake shrooms of
his I mean and nobody knows the cycle
will never stop it's going to be a
problem when people start getting pissed
at you because there's aren't as good or
whatever or like there's
fed oh God not mine but like you know I
can imagine have you guys is this is
that a thing I don't know but I don't
even want want to put it out there CU
talk people talk about it I'm saying I
people like wait I never heard of that
that's a great idea true fools are weird
weird believe that whole piece just in
case people are very odd cut it out
that's like the candy and razor blades
you got to cut it out he's got he will
he's going to slice it out with the
brand new computer yeah you got a new
computer yep you got to cut it
out you got to Nip Tuck you got to Nip
Tuck that [__] you got to nip tuck it
behind your thighs yeah cut it out I
yeah I was thinking Joey Joey Joey
Gladstone guys we're never going to stop
let's do this cuz if you're just down
with the Full House references like this
bro we're going to be here till 12 get
the [__] out but what was the name of
Joey's
puppet remember he was a ventriloquist
yeah and he had the puppet with the big
teeth with the shirt it was like a
little I what you're talking about
totally it was like a little chipmunk it
was a chipmunk what was the name oh [__]
someone's screaming at their TV right
now watching this live Googling right
now I hope so are you googling
it oh Marty's fast Marty's fast name of
Joey Gladstone's puppet Mr Woody M
woodchuck Mr woodchuck woodchuck yeah
look it that's that fool right there
that's that fool right there that's a
good picture right there he has no teeth
Yo his Mouse wide open oh that's edited
yeah he has no teeth what the
[__] all right
D the bottom he look like Boy George on
the bottom bottom left what happened to
him boy he just aged and he was like I'm
done with this him oh Joey glassstone
he's out there killing Lis Morris
headsets weren't they [__]
yeah married atlan Moret in this guy
we're [__] right I don't
know no I can't wait till you see this
because you went were they [__] the
way look [__] face when you said I'm
high as [__] right now I'm [__]
stoned
bro all right end on we'll end on the
Jagged Little
Pill what oh I was like you
say you were about to drink that what
the [__] is that mean jacking little
pills what the
[__] I'm not I'm not in touch with their
music good enough to know all right well
okay so Bole C on everything all right
guys yeah yeah just that's it yeah thank
you guys all right and when your podcast
comes out every just it drops
[__] whenever it drops it drops when it
drops at least at least twice a week at
least oh [__] yeah good [__] and then we
drop a freestyle every Friday and then
we just started a vlog Series so I just
did a the first one it actually did
really well it did 100K in 2 days which
is oh nice for our first Vlog we've
never did a vlog so uh and you're
monetized right yeah [__] B so we did
a uh uh Vlog at Tour on um burner's like
personal little cookies compound in the
bay that and I saw the Mexico te stuff
you just did too you at the shows and Sh
did you film that no I mean I would just
I just went oh okay I thought that was
part of like the but I am I think I'm
going to go to Texas and hog hunt with
him for the next Vlog the problem is I'm
a huge animal lover you're not going to
Li it Rosy's dad that's what he used to
do a lot you're not going to like it at
all cuz if they don't die from the shot
you get off with that knife too no no no
they do it they do it from a helicopter
oh the Machine Gun Tour oh they're just
gonna I've seen the videos yeah it looks
like a a video game it also looks like I
might have like R trauma afterwards I be
thinking like what was up with a poor
pigs I killed
bro
yeah I hope that he's just contemplating
like all for like all for Content you
know all the kills are damn I I kill 60
[__] Hogs I killed 60 [__] pombas
that's I was going to say they're whole
Timone and pumbas they're dead now they
have no homies one time I went and got
food in Hollywood came home and opened
my bag and there was a fly in my bag and
I thought this F's so far away from home
he was never going to see his family
again it's over for the F yeah he's
never making it back he's never making
it back nope no he's going to die he die
by himself it's like a Toy Story and
wood he doesn't get on the back of the
of the car and it's over all right guys
thank you so much for being here
appreciate you guys this has been the
Bole Kev episode from Bole Kev Marty and
I have a dope ass day that wouldn't have
stopped wow that would have never
stop what the [__] you really sat there
with that fly and you're like sorry bro
I did I felt hella
[Music]
bad
perfect
[Music]